All praise is due to Allah. We praise Him, seek His help, and ask for His forgiveness. We seek
refuge in Allah from the evil of our own souls and from the evil of
our deeds. Whomever Allah guides, none can lead astray, and whomever He leads astray, none can guide. I bear
witness that there is no god but Allah
alone, without any partner, and I bear witness that Muhammad is His servant and
Messenger. O you who have believed, fear Allah as He should be feared and do
not die except as Muslims.
O mankind, fear your Lord, who created you from
one soul and created from it its mate and dispersed from both of them
many men
and women. And fear Allah, through whom you ask one another, and the
wombs. Indeed, Allah is ever, over you, an Observer. O you who have believed,
fear Allah and speak words of appropriate justice. He will then
amend for you your deeds and forgive you your sins. And whoever obeys Allah and His Messenger has certainly attained a
great attainment. To
proceed: The truest of speech is the Book of Allah, and the best of guidance is the guidance of
Muhammad, peace and blessings be upon him. The
worst of matters are those that are newly invented, and
every newly invented matter is an innovation, and every innovation is misguidance, and every
misguidance leads to Hellfire. And after that, Allah, Blessed
and Exalted is He, says in His Book: “And We have not made for any
human being anything but a religion.”  Before you, there was eternity. If you die, then they are the ones who live forever.
Every soul will taste death, and We test you with evil and good as a trial, and to Us you will be returned. God Almighty. Every soul will taste death.
[Music] And
We test you with evil and good as a trial, and to Us you will be returned.
God Almighty.
[Applause]
Ali ibn Abi
Talib. God Almighty.
Fear of the
Almighty. God
Almighty. And work with the
barking and following, and
contentment with little.
[Music]
God Almighty. And
following every
soul. Person,
being, race, no matter what background, no matter.
From it We created you, and into it We will return you, and from it We will bring you forth once again.
God Almighty.
God Almighty. And this
worldly life is nothing but
play. And indeed, the Hereafter is the true life, if only they
knew. God Almighty. And indeed, the
Hereafter. God Almighty. But you prefer the
life of this world. The Hereafter is
better and
more lasting. After life is that longer.
Last
prop us about
Parade fire, the
prop
said, "
No ear has ever heard, nor has it ever crossed the mind of any
human being. May God bless him and grant him peace."
[Applause]
[Music]
What you sent that if I had such
and such, imagine if I could do such and
such, you try to get them to
it. Therein is nothing that has
ever been seen, an ear has
ever heard, never
cared about the heart of a human being. Anything that no minute thing
is amazing to people. We say
at the end of the sentence,
imagine that the prophet said there are things
in paradise that no one has ever even
imagined, it hasn't even come to
anyone's heart or mind. And this is what
you trade, this is what you give up. Do you exchange what is inferior for what is better?
And you give up that which is better for something you theorize, you night and day, the life of
this world, you let it
deceive you, you let that temporary
enjoyment cause you to have eternity. And on the Day when
the wrongdoer will bite his hands, he will say, "Oh, would that
I had taken a path with the Messenger."
Would take, "Oh, woe to me!
Oh, woe to me! Would that I had
not taken so-and-so as a friend. He led me astray from the
remembrance after it had come to me."
[Music] [
Applause]
Parade
[Music]
People, and God Almighty, and our Lord,
has seen and heard, so return
us to do
righteous deeds, so return us to do righteous deeds, certain of
paradication
[music]
to
God Almighty, and what
God Almighty has left, no, it is a
word He is saying, and behind
them is a barrier until the Day they are
resurrected.
God said therein, and do not speak to Me.
Here and
not
sister, God Almighty, and may God bless him and grant him peace [
music]
AT of people they find this topic to be
a negative topic and a topic that we do
n't really need to discuss that we
should brush under the carpet.  This is
why we are in calamities This is why we
are far away from our religion because
we're not remembering the
inevitable we don't remember the thing
that is going to take place the only
thing that you're guaranteed
in this dunia is that you're going to
die.   May God’s prayers and peace be upon him.
He
mentioned more than
[music]
this. Why, may God’s prayers and peace be upon him,
this?
Why you
[music]
interpret it.
Our God, the Most High, says:
But as for him who feared standing before his Lord and restrained himself from [following] his desires,
then Paradise will be his refuge. ... God, the Most High, says: Say, “Indeed, the death from which you flee - indeed, it will meet you. Then you will be returned to the Knower of the unseen and the witnessed, and He will inform you of what you used to do.”
Then you will be returned to the Knower of the unseen, and He will inform
you of what
you used to do. I say
this: I ask forgiveness of God for myself and for you, so seek His forgiveness. Indeed,
He is the Forgiving.  O Most Merciful, I send prayers
and peace upon our Prophet Muhammad, his family, and his companions. O Allah, we
ask You for a good end. O Allah, we ask You for a
good
end. O Allah, we ask You for a good end. O Allah, have mercy on our oppressed brothers and sisters in
Palestine, Sudan, and everywhere else, O Lord of
the Worlds.